today I'm going to talk about randomness
we ask and partially answer the question
is untrusted Randomness helpful
I'm weijing and this is a joint work
with Uma garage
so normally in randomize the algorithm
we have an input X of n Bits And The
algorithm has access to random bits uh
independently and unically drawn from 0
and 1.
in the case of space-bounded algorithm
these random disks came in as a string
and the algorithm generates an output
that can be seen as a function depends
on the input and the random bits
and for today's talk we only care about
decision problems so we assume that the
output is either 0 or 1.
now a priori a randomized algorithm can
use as many as the time limit number of
random bits but in reality uh truly
random bits are very rare and the people
are addressed this issue by taking
Notions of like pseudor Randomness or
weak random sources
however today we are going to talk about
a very strong notion of bad Randomness
in the sense that these Randomness are
untrusted that they can be adversely or
even maliciously chosen even upon seeing
the input X
of course just that just as it is this
model is not so interesting because if
these random bits can be a residually
chosen then we just choose them to be
all zeros and the algorithm is just as
strong as a deterministic algorithm
right
so we want the algorithm to have some
kind of ways to verify these random bits
that they can check these random bits
are truly random
so let's say we have a Pooler and a
verifier that are both efficient and
initially they are both given access to
an input X
now the proverb
also has access to a unlimited number of
random bits which to the verify or they
are untrusted because they can be
manipulated by the prover
the program and the verify interacts
with it with each other and eventually
the poorer needs to send the verifier
proof that you can think of it as
approved for relevance
and the verify needs to either accept
the proof and output an answer being
either 0 or 1 or it detects Something
Fishy in the proof and choose to abort
and outputs a perpendicular symbol that
represents I don't know
now if the verifier is deterministic and
we want the verifier to never be fooled
by a dishonest Brewer then you can see
that this model is exact is exactly the
zero error populistic model
so to make things more interesting we
also allow the verify to have its own
Randomness that are trusted and truly
random but only for a limited number of
random bits
now we Define this complexity class RPP
which represents robustly probabilistic
polynomial time
with the parameter K and we say a
language is in rppk
if there exists polynomial time plural
and polynomial type verifier such that
for every input
this protocol outputs the correct answer
with
a high probability while for any uncom
uh for any competitionally unbounded and
probably dishonest poorer P Prime this
protocol outputs either the correct
answer or I don't know with high
probability
and of course the verify could only use
order of K truly trusted random bits
now let's come back to the Viewpoint of
a randomized algorithm we can show that
the above interactive proof model is
equivalent to a randomized algorithm
that has access to two parts of random
bits where one part contains untrusted
random bits that can be adversely Chosen
and another part contains trusted random
bits that are always truly random but
only has a limited number of bits
and the algorithm
besides outputting zero or one it is
also allowed to put output I don't know
now a language is in this robustly
probabilistic polynomial time with
parameter k
if there exists a polynomial time
randomized algorithm with order of K
trusted Randomness such that for every
input
yes the untrusted random bits are indeed
truly random the algorithm outputs the
correct answer with high probability
while for every fix the value of the
untrusted random bits the algorithm
outputs either the correct answer or I
don't know with high probability and
this this probability is only over the
randomness of The Trusted render bits
so where does this class rppk stand
so let's first think of the case when
there are no untrusted render bits
and if the number of trusted random bits
is unbounded they correspond to the
class of PPT the abandoned bonded error
probabilistic polynomial time
and if the number of trusted random bits
is limited to order of K then we denote
this class by PPP with parameter k
and when K goes down to logarithmic of
the input size it can be fully
randomized so it is equivalent to having
zero random bits and the class is just
deterministic polynomial time p
now with unlimited number of untrusted
random bits we denote this class by rppk
and we say that when K goes down to zero
it is basically zero error probabilistic
so it's a cleft to VPP and actually it
is still in the pp when K is only
logarithmic in N so we have RPP login is
still equals to DPT
on the other side
when you have unlimited number of
trusted random lists the class is still
containing BBT
and from the definition rppk clearly
contains pvpk and we can show that it
actually contains bpdk with zpp articles
now
to answer the question is untrusted
random is helpful
it is only helpful when this containment
is strict
but with common belief everything in
this diagram should collapse to P so we
don't actually know if it is helpful or
not but there's indeed a conditional
separation that if pppk and CPP do not
contain one another then rppk is indeed
a strictly bigger Clause than both pppk
and CPP
now things are more interesting when you
consider log space robustly randomized
algorithms
we can similarly Define the class RPL K
that stands for robustly random
probabilistic loss space
and the languages in rplk if there
exists a log space algorithm with order
of K trusted random bits such that the
same thing holds that for every X if the
untrusted random base is truly random it
outputs the correct answer with high
probability while for every
adversarially fixed untrusted random
bits the probability of it outputting
either the correct answer or I don't
know is fine
now this class also has equivalent
formulation in the form of interactive
proofs although here the proofs the
protocols are not really interactive
anymore
we have that a language is in rplk even
only if there exists a lot of space
proverb that um that upon the input X
produce a proof pi x of polynomial
length and the log space verifier with
order of K random best that reads the
proof as a one pair string
so that with the honest proof it gets
the correct output with high probability
while for every possible proof
the through the verify either output is
the correct answer or outputs I don't
know with high probability
now what we know about Lost based
probabilistic computation is that the
best known to random generators have C
lens loss squaring
so we know that bounded error published
in log space can only use log square and
truly random bits and whether or not it
can be reduced to login so that it can
be fully randomized it's a very big open
problem
what we show in this work is that with
the help of untrusted random bits you
can actually reduce the number of
trusted random bits to log in
so in the form of this complexity
classes we have BPL equals to RPL with
login
truly random bits
and in this sense uh
for our current knowledge it means that
untrusted Randomness is indeed helpful
for log space communication
and here we are going to sketch a proof
for this result by designing a log Space
streaming proof for every language in
BTL
so for every language in BPL there is a
log space algorithm that solves it and
with every input X this algorithm can be
represented by a stochastic Matrix MX
that has entries either 0 1 or 1 half
that represents the transition Matrix
between the state between the memory
States in each step
so the dimension of the Matrix is M
which represents the number of possible
possible memory states which is
polynomial in n
this Matrix has the property that first
it is
uniformly computable from X in log space
and if we assume that the initial state
of the algorithm is State One
then the probability of reaching State I
at time T is exactly the
uh the entry in the ice row and the
first column in The Matrix that is the T
times power of MX
and we assume that there is only one
accepting state which is the state m
then the probability of the algorithm
accepts is the entry in the nth row and
the First Column and the Matrix that is
the Big T's time power of MX where Big T
is the time of the algorithm which is
polynomial in n
now what the proverb does is that for
every time T and every state I it
outputs a number that approximates this
Matrix entry that is the probability of
reaching State I at time t
and it can approximate this number up to
polynomially Small error just by
simulating the log space algorithm for
polynomial polynomial number of times
and we think of its output and strain
that contains the Big T number of
vectors where each Vector approximates a
distribution
the verifier what the verify does is
that it needs to check whether these uh
vectors that approximate distribution is
indeed the distribution of the original
algorithm that reaches the these states
in different time steps
so what it checks is that whether for
every T time T the difference between
the vector VT and the product of the
transition Matrix empty with VT minus
one is small
and it checks this by Computing the
following value d
so this T value looks complicated but to
parse it first we know that there's a
coefficient Alpha for every T time T and
state I these Alpha TI
are four wise independent random
variables taking values in minus one or
one and that each one of them has mean
zero
so they can be generated from Seas of
lens logarithm making n and each one of
them can be computed from the seeds in
log space
and the value in the parenthesis is
basically just the entries of this the
difference vectors that we want to show
that are small
and if we look at the if you change the
form of the formulation of D and look at
the coefficient between each vti the
coefficient can each one of them can be
computed in log space so the D value can
be computed by just taking a string of
ETI in log space
and we can show that if the difference
Vector has small L1 Norms say smaller
than Delta for every t
then with hyperability the T value is
smaller than some threshold say 30 times
Delta times t
and the verifier also knows the correct
answer by just looking at the last
number that the prover outputs the very
big T of State M because this number is
very close to the actual accept
probability of the original log space
algorithm
while on the other hand if the
difference between the final value that
the poorer outputs with the actual uh
accept probability is high so it's
larger than one force then by choosing
Delta to be a small enough number but
still polynomial in N we can show that
with high probability the speed value is
larger than the threshold of 30 times
Delta times t
and so what the verify actually does is
first to compute this D value and checks
that if it is larger than the threshold
or smaller if it is larger than a
threshold it means that the proof is not
really correct and the other boards
while if it is smaller than the
threshold it can safely decide the
output just by looking at whether the
last probability value is larger than
one half or smaller than one half in
which case with high probability it is
the correct answer
so to conclude we proposed two
hierarchies of robustly probabilistic
classes
that uses untrusted random bits and they
are robust in the sense that when they
are trusted random bits are adversely
chosen it still does not give the wrong
output with high probability
so for polynomial time this class rpk
using K trusted randomness
is sandwiched between BPP and zpp and
when K goes down to login it equals to
libidity so K range is from polynomial
to again
while for long Christmas space this
class RPL K is sandwiched between BPL
and zpl
and something I didn't mention is that
when K is equal to zero it is basically
zero error probabilistic log space so
it's the pl but it's still in vpl even
when K is constant so for log space k
ranges between login and the constant
with the common belief that BPP equals
to P mvpr equals to L both hierarchies
collapse
so showing any of these inclusions being
quality being equality is and intriguing
intermediate looking problem towards
proving the whole thing that BPP equals
to gpp or BPL equals to the pl
but we still don't know if the untrusted
random bits are helpful in the case of
polynomial time we kind of know it's
helpful for log space but it might be
just because of our lack of knowledge
for the randomizing log space
computation
but in the query model we can show that
there are indeed unconditional
separations between robustly randomized
algorithms and bounded error properly
standard reasons or zero error
probabilistic algorithms so in the last
slides let me show let me State the
result for these separations we show
that there is a promise problem with
input of size 2 to the N plus k for
every n and K such that first it can be
solved by a robustly randomized
algorithm using K trusted random bits
and end on trusted random bits with only
one query to the input
yeah
on the other hand any bounded error
randomized algorithm using less than n
uh trust the random best requires
exponentially and number of queries
also for any zero error randomized
algorithm with however many random
business uses it requires explanation
okay number of queries
so taking care for example to be login
we show that in this case untrusted
Randomness is unconditionally helpful in
the query mode
and that's all for this talk thank you